hello I've been asked to talk to you
about the crying a virus business grant
said you can apply for through the local
council we run a business from a Stalin
Industrial Estate I've been in business
over 30 years and the impact the
coronavirus had on our business has been
immense
without the grants that we applied for
when it first opened we wouldn't have
been able to survive it gave us the
opportunity to continue it gave us the
opportunity to have some breathing space
to think about where we wish to go with
our business the grant is just that it's
a grant you don't have to pay it back
we found that applying for the grant was
so easy I went online I put its warm
stroke I wasn't 100% sure that we would
get here is a time and you can imagine
our relief when the money appeared in
our bank account I might be saved at a
mount the same we've got him I would
urge you all to apply for it whether
you're sure you're gonna get it or not
it's gonna be a great benefit to you it
will help you have the confidence to
stay in business it will help you to
rebuild your business because we all
have a lot of thinking to do well none
of us know how long this is gonna go on
for I don't know at the end of this
where my business will be but I do know
at the moment we're still there was
still hope we're still fighting and
without that grant we wouldn't have been
able to a lot of people think it's a
loan and don't want to get into debt
it's not alone
it is a grant apply for it please and
give yourself a fighting chance to stay
in business